[Música]
y ahora hablamos de deportes como estaba
comentando con daniel hablando con juan
pupiales quien ya se está alistando para
hablar de un polémico caso la demanda
que hizo chile a la federación
ecuatoriana de fútbol porque
supuestamente hay un jugador dentro de
esa selección pues que no sería
ecuatoriano de origen de nacimiento sino
colombiano y puesto esta polémica que
estábamos hablando también en el día de
ayer cuando pues ya todo esto salió a la
luz y todos los medios de comunicación
no estaban reportando para ello entonces
está aquí -juan pupiales juan vamos a
seguir hablando de esta polémica por
favor hagamos un recuento para después
poder hablar con nuestro invitado si
vamos a comenzar con un poco de contexto
para que la gente entienda este caso de
estos casos legales siempre son algo
complejos como les hemos contado aquí
nuestras emisiones la federación chilena
de fútbol está denunciando que el
jugador ecuatoriano byron castillo nació
en colombia se falsificaron sus
documentos para omitir esta información
y habilitarlo para jugar con la
selección tricolor dice chile la fifa al
respecto abrió un procedimiento
disciplinario ante este caso
byron disputó ocho partidos en las
eliminatorias sudamericanas al mundial
de qatar 2 22 en las que ecuador terminó
en la cuarta posición y clasificó de
manera directa a la copa mundo el
jugador de 23 años hubo en las victorias
de ecuador contra chile venezuela
bolivia y paraguay que fueron en el
último tramo de estas eliminatorias
desde septiembre del año pasado el
ecuador se ha defendido y asegura que
byron nació en la ciudad de general
villamil playas desestimando la denuncia
de chile que acabó séptima en las
eliminatorias y por tanto no va al
mundial de qatar vamos a abordar este
tema con antonio quintero él es abogado
especialista en derecho del deporte que
nos atiende desde la ciudad de caracas
en venezuela antonio primero que todo
muchas gracias por estar con nosotros
qué significa que la fifa haya abierto
este expediente contra frente a la
denuncia de chile
muchísimas gracias por la invitación
saludos a todos lo único que significa
es que básicamente
la fifa va a investigar la situación
denunciada va a observar qué es lo que
está proponiendo chile cuál es la
denuncia pero es la fifa quien va a
decidir si estas pruebas digamos son
válidas o no si decide continuar con la
investigación y luego va a tomar una
decisión al respecto
y eso es lo que está sucediendo es un
procedimiento normal completamente
atom y también le quería preguntar qué
infracciones entonces estaría cometiendo
en la federación ecuatoriana según esta
denuncia de chile y de acuerdo también
con la normativa de la fifa no
es difícil decirlo porque en un primer
momento no podemos saber qué es lo que
está cometiendo la federación
ecuatoriana podemos hablar de byron
castillo que pudiera estar
falsificando documentos supuestamente y
en dado caso de que esto fuera así si la
federación ecuatoriano hubiera sabido
esto y no hubiera hecho nada
al respecto entonces la federación
ecuatoriana pudiera estar violando el
artículo 22.3 del código disciplinario
de la fifa que básicamente nos indica
que cuando se convoca un jugador
irregularmente es decir cuando convoca a
alguien que no puede ser convocado
alguien que no tiene la nacionalidad de
tu país por ejemplo
entonces estás cometiendo una violación
a la integridad de las competiciones y
en ese sentido se pueden aplicar medidas
disciplinarias algunas de estas medidas
pueden ser la exclusión la derrota de
partidos
en la exclusión de competencias pero es
una de las medidas no son las únicas y
todavía es como muy complejo la
situación es una situación compleja pero
es la pregunta que nos hacemos todos el
agua usted que es un experto puede toda
esta situación terminar en algún tipo de
cambio dentro de la eliminatoria mundial
de qatar-2022 que como recordamos tiene
a ecuador dentro de esa clasificación
del mundo de qatar y tiene a chile fuera
de la copa mundo
pero por ahora es poco probable por qué
razón todavía es poco probable bueno
como determina es la falsificación de
documentos de un jugador y cuando un
país te dice que tiene sus documentos
originales
básicamente va a poder chile o la fifa o
la federación de chile decir que el
documento que emitió ecuador es falso
tendría que ir a un juicio en ecuador y
demostrarlo a ecuador y que cuando
reconozca la propiedad falsedad a los
documentos lo segundo es que incluso
demostrando la falsedad de los
documentos lo segundo es que bueno que
la federación ecuatoriana hubiera sabido
en la situación porque si no le vas a
aplicar una sanción a la federación
cuando ella pudiera haber sido víctima
de esta situación también en dado caso
que se demuestre que byron castillo es
es culpable y aún así habiendo logrado
estas dos incluso tendríamos que
observar el tema de que tiene que ver
con que la sanción sea la que quiere
chile que se aplique donde ella salga
beneficiada lo cual es difícil porque
ahí va un rango de sanciones distintas
entonces hay varios obstáculos que
superar que por ahora se ven difíciles
hay que ver qué son cuáles son las
pruebas que tienen chile para decir lo
que está diciendo claro antonio en ese
orden días entonces esto sería más que
todo un caso contra castillo en cambio
de la selección ecuatoriana de fútbol
porque digamos que si él diga tiene la
nacionalidad ecuatoriana pues puede
jugar normalmente en esa selección y
como usted lo dijo también la selección
pudiera alegar siéndolo así que ella
también fue víctima pues de un engaño
por parte de este jugador entonces ahí
ya la demanda sería no contra la
federación ecuatoriana de fútbol sino
contra un individuo específico que
habría cometido irregularidades y así se
determina en el caso de su nacionalidad
ecuatoriana
bueno la tarea de primero en la denuncia
de chile es demostrar que byron
falsificó y luego que la federación
ecuatoriana estaba estado acabó en
principio en una denuncia contra byron
que se puede extender a la federación
ecuatoriana y puede generar su
descalificación lo cual es muy poco
probable y habría que tendríamos que ver
las pruebas pero en principio es más o
menos como lo dices
y antonio el mundial está muy cerca poco
más de seis meses y todo a poco más de
seis meses y todos estos temas legales
requieren de mucho tiempo se puede
apelar por los plazos que estamos
manejando en el peor escenario contra la
federación ecuatoriana de fútbol que
habría una decisión de cara al mundial
que comienza en noviembre
si hay hay una pequeña posibilidad la
comisión disciplinaria de fifa pudiera
decidir este caso rápidamente y si lo
decidiera en contra de la federación
ecuatoriana la federación ecuatoriana
debería apelar a la comisión de
apelaciones debería solicitar la
suspensión de la decisión y ahí tarda un
poco más la situación y después debería
apelar al tas y lograr que en el estás
solicitar una medida cautelar para que
se detenga la ejecución de la decisión
algo parecido a lo que ocurrió con paolo
guerrero ya desde la comisión de
apelaciones se puede apelar la decisión
de suspender
cualquier sanción que se le imponga
ecuador no ahora si por el contrario la
decisión va en contra de lo que propone
chile o de la denuncia interpuesta por
chile entonces en este caso va a ser
mucho más difícil y cuesta arriba para
chile
que el chileno tiene como apelar chileno
tiene como era arriba e incluso si logra
así
que básicamente sería porque tienen que
obtener una decisión rápido y no lo
vemos sucediendo antes del mundial en el
caso de que salga en contra de chile la
respuesta a la pregunta del mundial otra
pregunta que se hace mucha gente en perú
no una nuestra audiencia en perú llaman
a expresar sus posiciones la fifa a la
federación ecuatoriana de fútbol y
también a la federación peruana de
fútbol porque a perú
es una gran pregunta me la pregunta todo
el día de ayer es porque cambian de
posiciones es perú esta creo que en el
quinto lugar si mal no recuerdo si lee
con esta situación pero qué pasaría al
cuarto lugar entonces llaman a saber la
posición de perú porque su posición
sería alterada y pasaría de un posible
repechaje a una clasificación directa y
quien entraría en el repechaje pudiera
ser chile de acuerdo a lo que propone
chile
interesante esa s reconteo para terminar
antonio hay algún antecedente que
tengamos en la fifa en este comité
respecto a otro caso de falsificación
documental al que se puede aferrar la
federación chilena
porque no hay ningún caso sumamente
parecido o sea sumamente igual con
falsificación de documentos pero si hay
un caso de mala nacionalización es el de
nelson cabrera nelson cabrera un jugador
que hizo un trámite para cambiar su
nacionalidad y en ese caso creo que fue
con bolivia si mal no recuerdo para las
eliminatorias de rusia y en ese caso el
procedimiento no estuvo bien hecho y
jugó antes de obtener el reconocimiento
de la nueva nacionalidad y en ese
sentido
bolivia fue penalizado pero en ese caso
se utilizó otra vía que fue la protesta
por la alineación indebida que no es la
que se está utilizando en ese en este
caso en particular y que tiene una
consecuencia más directa de pérdida de
ciertos partidos y de otorgar los puntos
a la persona contraria al equipo
contrario como tal eso es lo más
parecido que podemos encontrar esto se
ve muy difícil prácticamente la
federación de chile se tiene que
enfrentar contra el sistema
de reconocimiento de documentos de
ecuador para demostrar de que este
documento falsificado etcétera etcétera
etcétera y luego de eso decir en la
federación ecuatoriana está involucrado
en esto para poder obtener eso por ahora
se ve difícil vamos a ver cómo avanza la
situación porque bueno con este mundial
pareciera que todo es posible